one two three four  [Music]  she don't worry about tomorrow  she's got plenty on her mind  don't have to bake stealer baro  just snaps her little fingers and they  all stand in line  she's never heard the word division  she don't defend nor deny  in a breach she's got every single piece  she needs to survive and attack her by  her side  she can paint the sun at midnight  roll out the moon  [Music]  [Music]  she knows just how to turn your tables  she'll leave you tongue-tied  [Music]  she lights up every silver  screen and if you dare to wish her well  you better watch yourself cause all bets  are off she'll take you for everything  she can feed some at midnight  roll out the moon after breaking day  [Music]  if you're so fortunate to love her  don't let a moment pass you by  she'll be on the move again before you  even say the word goodbye  [Music]  many ways  [Music]  [Applause]  oh